معنا من باريس الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
برونو جي دي ومن باريس ايضا جمال ابينا
الناشط النقابي
والعمال ابدا بك سيد برونو اليس من حق
هؤلاء ان يتظاهروا ويحتجوا ويضغطوا على
الحكومه والرئيس مانويل ماكرون ليتراجع
نعم لديهم الحق بالتظاهر والتظاهر هو حق
مكفول في الدستور الفرنسي ويمكنهم ان
يتظاهروا وهذا ما سمحت به الحكومه اذا
المظاهرات جرت في كل البلدات والمدن
الفرنسيه
وشاهدنا ما حصل في الاسبوع الماضي فيما
يتعلق باعمال بالعنف ولكن الان نجد
اعدادا متزايده من الشباب يعبرون عن الصوت
ضد الحكومه
وفي هذا الاسبوع والاسبوع المقبل توحدت
النقابات في موقفها التصاعدي ضد الحكومه
وهناك قرار المجلس الدستوري والذي هو سوف
يفصل بالنسبه الى ما اذا كان هذا القانون
بشان اصلاح سوف يكون نافذا ام لا سيد
بناها هل هذا حل مناسب برايك ليكون هناك
قول فصل
ديجا فاصل
في الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن حق مكفول
دستوريا وبالتالي يتعين على اي تشريع ان
يمر عبر الجمعيه العامه وليس ان يتم بشكل
امر تنفيذي نحن نتحدث عن ديموقراطيه
تمثيليه للشعب في فرنسا
ومجلس النواب هو الذي يجب ان يمثل صوت
الشعب يعني لا يمكن ان يكون هناك مجلس
دستوري يفصل في دستوريه هذه القوانين
وبالتالي تصبح النافذه هل هذا يمكن ان
يكون حلا يرضي الجميع سيدي بنا
بالنسبه الى المجلس الدستوري
يمكن ان نشرح دور هذا
المجلس هذا المجلس ينظر في القوانين
ولكننا نتحدث عن قرار حكومي وبالتالي هذا
التشريع التشريع يمر عبر الجمعيه العامه
والشعب الفرنسي ممثل في هذه الجمعيه
العامه في مجلس النواب وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن مبدا مرتبط
بالديمقراطيه وليس بقرارات تنفيذيه حكوميه
وبالتالي الدستور الفرنسي يقفل هذا الحق
للشعب الفرنسي وهذا ما يعبر عنه الفرنسيون